en australia mi vida se ha convertido en
el primer indígena en ganar el
prestigioso premio archibald con un
autorretrato titulado con su propio
nombre main
ojalá se abra la puerta para que muchos
más artistas indígenas reciban estos
premios en word these roads park sounds
of mine es un actor conocido en
australia por su activismo contra el
racismo
sabuni françois chi kung a recibió el
premio nansen un galardón otorgado por
acnur en reconocimiento a su labor con
los refugiados en aquí vale en uganda
allí ha sido profesora de inglés ya ha
acompañado a mujeres víctimas de
violencia sexual y de género
teaching me siento muy bien enseñando a
mujeres y niñas en esta situación
situacións
nichols
bueno cuando estamos ocupadas no estamos
inactivas y eso nos hace pensar en el
futuro agua mind
tus focas con 18 secunda es también
refugiada huyó del genocidio de uganda
fue esclava en república democrática del
congo y finalmente llegó a uganda donde
ha ofrecido ayuda a más de 1000 mujeres
[Música]
en la isla turística de tioman en
malasia todos los fines de semana un
grupo de voluntarios se junta para
recolectar plástico y evitar que llegue
al océano
después lo reciclan y lo transforman en
nuevos productos todo está envuelto en
plástico en estos días por lo que es
difícil combatir su uso entonces con el
reciclaje surge la posibilidad de
limpiar el medio ambiente y convertir el
plástico en artículos útiles
una solución al problema de los residuos
plásticos en un país como malasia donde
cada habitante consume 16 kilos de media
al año
[Música]
una tutoría en una acera es nueva delhi
en india donde una cantante vino gupta y
su marido ante los efectos de la
pandemia en la educación decidieron
abrir una escuela en la calle
no tienen acceso a internet sus escuelas
son cerrados y no tienen medios para
aprender es muy difícil de aceptar que
durante la pandemia estos niños se
queden en casa y no hagan nada
y poco a poco sus clases han ido ganando
estudiantes de entre 4 y 14 años
mientras gupta espera que más
voluntarios se sumen al proyecto e
impartan clases
fabio gomes es un artista urbano
brasileño su vida estuvo rodeada de
dificultades y de repente un mural de
una mujer negra con el cabello
convertido en un frondoso cerezo se
viralizó hasta llegar a la oscarizada
actriz viola davis quien lo compartió
con el mensaje de lo amo gómez a lo
largo de su vida ha pintado más de 300
murales anónimos hasta ahora cuando su
carrera puede dar un giro a la fama
[Música]
fahim amir sa es una joven afgana que
desafía la discriminación de género
desde el baile lo hace con la danza sufí
liderando a un grupo de hombres y
mujeres una afición que lleva a cabo
pese al rechazo de grupos extremistas
como el estado islámico el talibán a la
posibilidad de que las mujeres puedan
bailar